[Applause]
thank you
retrieves it
got to the rim and couldn't finish Kai
Jones when banana with good Rim
protection and that's how he changes the
equation Doris oh my goodness the length
is gonna take people by surprise how
about that fasting up his teammate
Dominic Barlow five on the shot clock
that's three years long and Brandon with
the board
Pace to this game nice rim run by
wendbanyana and one and there it is he
does a feel to what he does so feels the
initial defender on his back it's kind
of striking to see it is but he's we've
seen him make a number of clean switches
already and look at that he hijacked
that one
at the other end but you were talking
about this his ability to guard on the
perimeter he said it multiple clean
switches and how much
15 to go
mcallen's
man when benyama put him in the friend
zone barefoot
it just comes over in rotation
that's a game changer it is
kicks it out to champigny
and laces the three from deep and McCoy
misses the 15-footer
[Applause]
[Music]
Scott on the drive and when banyama with
his fourth block
y set a great screen when beniana
switches on to him
Bailey got hung up and had to fire it at
the end of the shot clock good defense
by San Antonio
Champaign picks the handoff I do like
the new challenge rule but you get to
keep it there it is and maybe a
four-point play
shooting night for victorious last one
was well off that one under duress with
some